kiss me what public displays of
affection make people very uncomfortable
yes i do
some of our favorite marvel actors have
gotten rather friendly on screen with
each other that's no surprise they are
actors capable of many things of course
here's just some of our faves that we
bet you haven't heard about yet oh also
we're going to end everyone by writing
them as a couple in their marvel
characters let's go
number one can we tell you something in
secret oscar isaac plays laurent leclerc
who seduces a woman named teres rakin
she's played by the beloved elizabeth
olsen of course scarlet witch and moon
knight we can get behind this pairing
witches get power from the moon or
something don't they great couple but we
still prefer vision
we give this shipping seven out of ten
number two we could see the atom project
being a deadpool plotline quite recently
the atom project came out bringing to us
the dynamic of reynolds and saldana
hi
she plays laura shane adam's wife and a
fellow time pilot left stranded in 2018
after a failed attempt on her life a
better dynamic though would be their
marvel personas deadpool and gamora we
give this couple a 10 out of 10 because
they would either destroy each other or
fall madly in love and either way we
want to see that it takes me seven tries
to get something right
but i am not a quitter
number three the cringy captain america
can go west
the witch and the super soldier found
love in a movie called ingrid goes west
in 2017 just a couple years before
falcon and the winter soldier olson and
russell play husband and wife in the
movie
not technically but you know yeah yeah
they are olson plays a narcissistic
social media influencer and russell
plays a painter now if wanda and john
walker got together wanda would most
definitely obliterate him we give this
imaginary couple one out of ten yeah and
they're really entertaining to work on
number four stuck between the devil and
the deep blue sea the actors found love
on screen in deep blue sea via a
passionate affair when rachel weiss's
character hester cheats on the high
court judge with hiddleston's character
it does not end very well in a weird way
we could see loki and melina vostakov
yelena and natasha's mom may be possibly
getting along we give this imaginary
couple six out of ten and it's a
fascinating dynamic i think number five
their on-screen chemistry is electric
paul bettany played the man who
developed the theory of evolution
charles darwin himself and jennifer
connelly played his wife of course paul
and jennifer didn't meet filming
creation they actually met filming a
beautiful mind but they played lovers in
creation jarvis vision and karen slash
suit lady would make the ultimate couple
that would take over the world we give
this totally non-fictitious couple a 10
out of 10. you can't tell us karen and
jarvis aren't secretly online dating
that's just canon
number six we find this pairing just a
wee bit
strange scarlett johansson played mary
bolin in the movie the other bolin girl
based on the real story and she married
benedict cumberbatch's character william
carey however king henry viii had eyes
on mary and a reluctant affair began
that affair was reluctant because not
only did mary know it was happening so
did her husband who kind of had to agree
because you know henry was a king yay
after the bull doctor strange pulled and
no way home we couldn't see natasha
romanov putting up with his shenanigans
even if she were still alive so yeah we
can't give them better than a three out
of ten
number seven dr palmer could outwit tony
stark as well as irene could outwit
sherlock rachel mcadams played a femme
fatale irini adler from new jersey who
outwitted sherlock holmes on several
occasions
why couldn't you just come away with me
it is implied that they had an
intermittent hotly consummated affair
doctor strange would totally obliterate
tony stark if tony got with dr palmer
also she's too good for iron man should
have led with that they're stuck with a
two out of ten the ladies do like
the cumberbatch yes number eight do you
think rachel mcadams or jake gyllenhaal
are left-handed in southpaw jake
gyllenhaal plays the professional boxer
billy the great hope who's living with
his wife maureen played by rachel
mcadams and their daughter we think dr
palmer would actually get along better
with mysterio than rdj despite the fact
mysterio's pure evil four out of ten
number nine an octopus and a god walk
into a bar the 2002 film frida based on
the painter freda cowell had one of the
greatest love stories ever which was
reflected on the screen
irl diego was 20 years older than his
love and the actors themselves molina is
13 years older than selma hayek there's
no reason the couple of ajax and doc awk
would work out and there's really no
reason it wouldn't change our mind 5 out
of 10 for just being plain old meh
number 10. up and coming lovers the
psychological thriller don't worry
darling is set to premiere this year
with florence pugh and harry styles
playing lovers hard to picture florence
in romances after her solid performance
in black widow but yes she did play
lovers with harry styles in the mcu it's
a weird combo but hey we like weird 7
out of 10 it would be pretty decent and
we trust each other and if at any point
you know we can stop whenever and all
that kind of stuff number 11 there were
sparks between them in the huntsman
chris played a warrior named eric as
well as jessica chastain's character
sarah's husband at least until she was
thought to have been done in by princess
freya's magic oddly we do not think thor
and the villain from x-men dark phoenix
would make the worst of couples out
there but the hero villain thing sure
puts a damper on it 5 out of 10 for
another meh couple we don't really want
to see
it was great it was so funny a lot of
action in the movie wasn't there number
12. just imagine black widow buying a
zoo you may have forgotten matt damon's
cameo in thor when he played an actor
playing loki but we sure haven't he and
scarlett johansson played lovers in we
bought a zoo matt damon played benjamin
me who you guessed it bought a zoo and
also fell in love with johansen's
character kelly foster and if we're
standing near each other on new year's
we'll do this again sometime
we get the feeling that natasha romanov
is not interested in dating actors we
give this mcu shipping two out of ten
why two and not one well
we don't really know the guy well enough
to fairly assess
number 13 dave bautista is a lovable guy
my spy came out in 2020 and it was the
funniest movie ever if you haven't seen
it do yourself the favor bautista's
character jj partners up with the itty
bitty sophie who's like nine years old
to do some spy stuff and then he falls
in love with her mom played by parisa
fitzhenley
stumbling into our lives has been a
breath of fresh air
drax is a super lovable guy we could see
things working out all right with riva
connors seven out of ten because it
isn't our favorite shipping but it would
all work out fine
number 14 bondurant
names this similar are a semblance of a
poor screenwriter in the crime drama
film lawless tom hardy plays a character
named forrest bondurant who's running a
moonshine business and marries dancer
and waitress maggie beauford venom plus
the villain who can make stuff levitate
that's a weird couple that we can
totally support 10 out of 10. that's
only our third perfect score by the way
one minute you're married to a machine
the next you're dating the moon being an
actor can definitely be a weird
experience at times
do you ever think the actors have a hard
time leaving past on-screen
relationships at the door when they end
up in a new movie together let us know
your thoughts in the comments and thanks
for hanging out with us here at the
things
you